alright so since this is my thesis
defense I've been getting a lot of
advice on how to proceed one of the
pieces of advice I got this morning was
that the best defense is a strong
offense so try to be very offensive so
with that I'd like to move forward into
the work that I've been working on for
the last couple of years today I'm going
to talk to you about dynamic procedure
aids a method for supporting emergency
response so we looked at the domain of
medicine medicine is compelling because
it has massive scale there were thirty
three point six million admissions to us
hospitals over the course of one year
and three hundred and 234 million
worldwide surgeries over the course of
one year in addition it has huge impact
helping people lead longer healthier
lives now why Crisis Response an
emergency medicine well there we go from
human factors literature we know that
people perform the worst during highly
stressful situations and when they are
bored or when they are over stressed and
doctors will be dealing doctors who deal
with emergency medicine are the first to
tell you that their work is hours of
boredom followed by moments of sheer
terror second this is a good example of
why does that not one ah the clicker
there we go clicker like skipping okay
so this is a good example of a
philosophy and hcf designing for extreme
users or lead users if we can figure out
how to do things right in the middle of
a cardiac arrest response many of those
ideas should transfer over to the
routine activities of day-to-day
medicine so how do we improve Emergency
Medical Response we argue it is by
reducing errors so there's a very
influential medical study called the
Harvard study which estimated that in
the US there were between 44,000 and
98,000 preventable deaths per year so
these are dare these are deaths where
some kind of human error was involved
and here air is defined as the failure
of a planned action to be completed as
intended or the use of a wrong plan to
achieve a name
it's important to mention here that
medical errors don't happen because
doctors are incompetent or unskilled
doctors do between 30,000 and 60,000
hours of training depending on their
specialty rather medicine as it exists
now is too complicated for any one
person to always get it right these
procedures are at the edge of tractable
complexity errors are easy to make yet
the perilous environment is severely
unforgiving to even small errors some
experts like Deming believe that the
only way to reduce errors in this kind
of environment is by improving process
so today I'm the primarily going to talk
to you about error mitigation and
emergency medicine with a specific focus
on cardiac arrest all the way believe
these ideas will extend to other domains
so let's dive into creating dynamic
procedure aids over the course of 16
months we spent more than 50 hours
observing realistic simulated operating
room crisis response at Stanford with
our collaborators crisis simulation was
pioneered at Stanford by dr. David GABA
who inspired by his experience as an
amateur airplane pilot the goal of these
simulations is to teach and evaluate
crisis response these simulations are
engineered to be highly realistic using
a very sophisticated robot mannequin
patient real Oh our staff and equipment
and broadway theatre levels of
production let's watch a part of a
crisis simulation
so anesthesiologist the woman on the
left may split visual attention between
a vitals display the patient preparing a
drug vial and simultaneously ensuring
that other staff continue high quality
CPR during a crisis in this example we
see that the anesthesiologist on the
left has just started to notice that
there's an error happening and they're
about to communicate this error to the
surgeons
speaking of fast he's getting techie
verdict now what are you up to it so
this is an example of these are two good
examples in this video one of them is
vigilance the anesthesiologist is paying
attention and notices when the heart
rate starts to change the second is that
there's good teamwork here there's a
comedian communication of the problem to
the surgeon even before it becomes a
crisis now there's going to be a lot of
good examples in this video because this
video is actually designed as an example
of good practical skills for
anesthesiologist in crisis response so a
couple minutes later another
anesthesiologist in the front has joined
and is there to start helping oxygen
volatile want you to watch it as this
crash cart comes in the second
anesthesiologist grabs some paper
cognitive aids from this cart you're in
charge of the CPR quality okay you're
doing a hundred times a minute sandy let
me know when you yet when you get tired
you're kicking I get my many stuff for a
second IV please yo and the pressure I
the crisis proceeding backward they
start walking through each of the items
that's on this checklist now there's
something important here this happened
just at the end when he had to go to get
the backboard he put down the paper
cognitive aids let's see that one more
time it's on the back of the code cart
right there this is actually a very
common occurrence when using cognitive
aids or checklist in the operating room
because you need your hands to do things
however it's actually very common that
the checklists will never be picked back
up again somebody gets distracted and
they never get back around to it in this
video you will see them pick it back up
again because again it's an example of
good practice another thing to notice is
where it gets put it gets put on the top
of a crash cart this is a common place
to put all kinds of things such as
clipboards where people are taking notes
or when the defibrillator gets shifted
around so often things will actually end
up on top of the checklist so two more
minutes in we suddenly have a whole
bunch of new faces there's still two
people doing CPR now we have one person
setting an IV we have one person
prepping an IV bag one person who's
about to start come on the screen and
start setting the defibrillator paddles
the lead for the crisis and the support
and see geologist for the crisis many
codes also have a dedicated pharmacist
for prepping drugs one to two people to
ventilate or give air and potentially
even several other surgeons interns or
nurses in the room so this is actually a
relatively small code situation that's
where 1097 they drop quickly I'm going
to listen to the long sense hands on
please thank you so in this clip I want
to keep you I want you to keep track of
the technology being used as there's a
lot already in this environment but lead
anesthesiologist is now using a
stethoscope dealing with the ventilator
machine the vitals display for the
patient is up and to the right off the
screen down below the screen now to the
left you see a defibrillator and to the
right they've just wheeled in a big
machine which is a heart echo
if we're going to add something this
environment we want to make sure that
we're not going to be overloading the
team anymore than they already are the
second drawer ibly hypothermia
hyperthermia whisper 36 for no family
history we knew of let me say low res so
there's one more thing that I want to
point out about this video even though
it's an example of good practice we
actually have an error slip by unnoticed
if you see here there's a little
inflatable green bag which is on the
ventilation machine this bag being
inflated means that the ventilation
machine is not currently circulating air
into the patient and this can actually
cause some of the issues that they're
actually seeing some of the symptoms
that they're seeing so how did this
happen let's take another quick look and
this time keep your eye on that bag he
or she switched the manual from
automatic which inflates the bag and
allows pretty control the amount of
Oxford the next put in resume CPR and
now they've moved on without reflecting
on the fact that that was actually never
switched back to automatic so everything
in this video says practical skills
matter the things that they don't teach
you in medical school are also really
important such as teamwork vigilance and
situational awareness so prior work is
looked at what are these practical
skills or also called non-technical
skills that are important in this
environment one of them is task
management this is examples of this are
planning and preparing identifying and
utilizing resources the second one is
team working here we might be doing
exchanging of information using
authority and assertiveness or
supporting others third identified as
situational awareness so this might be
gathering information recognizing and
understanding or anticipating problems
and finally decision making so here we
have identifying options balancing risks
and selecting options and re-evaluating
the situation as it progresses so some
examples of good teamwork which we saw
in this video are confirmation of
responsibilities you make sure that
everybody knows what their role is and
discussing the case with their
colleagues you make sure that as soon as
an error is or as soon as the issue
arises you're letting the other people
in the room know so they can make
appropriate decisions some examples of
poor situational awareness which we
didn't really see in this video are no
confirmation meaning that somebody asks
you to do something and you don't
acknowledge it or you're distracted from
your monitoring's if something comes up
and you're not looking at the patient
when an important vitals change happens
so throughout this observation and hour
later participate sign we are trying to
answer the question can we design an aid
that will be better at reducing errors
than those existing paper aids that
they're using well in order to know that
will actually have to understand a
little bit better what are those
existing aids that they're using doctors
have begun to adopt risk management
techniques from aviation such as
training and simulation crew resource
management and the use of checklists
checklists are hailed as a vessel of
safety culture and that the overarching
purpose of checklist is that the
standard ation standardization of
commonly accepted efficient efficacious
practice Harrison at all found that
anesthesia care teams improve their
performance the more that they use such
aids as checklists so checklist the
benefits of checklist generalized to
procedurally organized knowledge which
are often Lee called cognitive aids
here's the cognitive aid book designed
by our collaborators here at Stanford
and in one of the studies and Salmond in
a tool go on days book on checklists and
hospitals of different types and
countries introducing checklist some
major complications from surgery dropped
thirty-six percent and deaths
forty-seven percent the performance of
checklists does not always live up to
the promise however good old animations
looking into the literature we get some
sense for why this might be there can be
some studies have shown great success in
cognitive aids some other studies have
actually shown no results so there's
some mixed results on whether or not
cognitive a's are really helping
cognitively checklists can sometimes
interrupt workflow for example finding
and searching checklist can induce
additional time attentional demand and
complexity researchers found that the
time governs willingness and compliance
of use in checklists so how long does it
take to use them however in
Psychological terms it actually be that
the perceived time of use maybe a more
salient variable here this procedural
interference and cultural skepticism has
slowed checklist adoption by medical
teams other checklists are increasingly
being used only a few have explored the
personnel experience and those that have
find barriers such as the checklist
slowing down or otherwise disrupting the
procedure in order for checklist to make
a positive benefit there must be buying
from head physicians and support from
administration and though current
checklists often provide benefits their
cost of impeded changes in medical
practice this leads us to believe that a
stronger benefit to cost ratio could
help tip the scales so through our
observation and participatory design
work with our collaborators we found
four needs and illustrate these needs
through a style that was actually
inspired by our final design
was ready access the nays need the aides
need to be available immediately and
they need to be not hidden and not
covered up rapid assimilation the aides
need to be used very quickly on the
order of seconds professional acceptance
so here we need some buy-in from the
people in the room they need to want to
use it and they need to have practiced
with it and limited attention everyone
in the room has limited attention and
designing for that is going to be key
let's move to the first item so in the
video you saw when the when the doctor
put down the cognitive aid on to the
crash cart there actually was the
opportunity for things to get put on it
and as we've seen in many simulations
things do get put on top of the
cognitive aids and they never get picked
back up again so one of the key concepts
for a design is we want to make them
visible to the team and we decided to do
that through large screen displays here
we have an example of a large screen
display on the wall on the left in front
of the anesthesiologist and behind the
anesthesiologist we have another large
screen display on the crash cart that
gets rolled in along with a tablet and
all of these have mirrored content if
you like a top-down view here's another
way of looking at it mayor the displays
so our design instantiation here was
making a display and interaction across
multiple large screens and tablets and
this helps address the problem by
providing a shared context facilitates
finding the checklist and helps them
provide more detail upon request
so let's look at rapid assimilation here
the key concepts are that we need to be
able to do each task with the aid in one
multitasking cycle however long that
takes you need to focus on what you
people are doing now in the room by
using the context and where they are in
the procedure we want to really simplify
to the display to make it quick to read
and we want to help by actually
designing a new shorter syntax that will
help people with speed reading and
search so prior research is done a great
job of externalizing best practices and
getting them into the o.r but we think
these aids have ignored effective visual
design and because they are static they
can't take advantage of some of the
concept that we think are important for
rapid assimilation so in our design we
actually only show the information of
the a that's relevant to the current
context and in some sense we're cheating
here by putting things on a computer and
making less content visible well that's
kind of the point we want to take
advantage of the dynamic properties of
the computers so here the design
instantiation was the progressive aid
protocol so how do we show certain parts
of the aid relevant to the context that
they're in and there's one more thing
that I talked about which is a concise
language for expressing things so we
developed a way of condensing the
verbiage that's used in the cognitive
aids a we call object action so here's
an example of two list items from the
existing cognitive paper cognitive aids
and this is what they might look like
after you've put them into object action
form so here what we've done is we've
brought out the main term out front
highlighted that for quick scanning and
we've put the extra details a little bit
subdued off to the right of that
we also try to remove as many of the
words as possible so we don't need words
like width or if and we try to really
condense that language down so here the
design instantiation was again the
progressive ated protocols and the
object action compressible language this
helps address the problem by helping
things be faster to read skim and search
due to fewer words a stereotype syntax
and better information mapping we're
going to help here make things
processable in small units of time for
multitasking so let's move on to
professional acceptance so one of the
things that we found was that people who
if you weren't going to use the aid
during non crisis there's no way you
were going to remember to use the aid
during crisis so in particular we wanted
to reframe our checklist as part of a
larger resource management system each
time a team member would like to gather
resource information they could look up
at the same screen whether it's crisis
or not and resource information here
could be things like who are the people
in the room or who's scheduled to be in
the room what is the short list of the
patient's medical history or what drugs
you have in the room and what kind of
like blood is available outside of the
room we hope to lower the activation
energy for acquiring information by
getting people in the habit of looking
up at the screen and facilitate
serendipitous reminding and create the
habit of more frequent consulting of
these resources our design work also
uncovered desires for many additional
interesting features in this space
including timelines or event records of
activity embedding patient vitals within
our display and even keeping track of
each member of the crisis team is
working on in the end however it turned
out that simplicity and speed far
outweigh the potential benefits of these
features for our stakeholders and so
they were removed
so again we wanted to reframe the
checklist as part of a larger resource
management system and here our design
instantiation was rapid access to team
names supplies calculators references
and allow the aide to transition from
routine to crisis mode upon demand this
helps address the problem by providing
incentive to use the system
familiarizing and habituating the
practitioners to use it finally let's
move on to the limited attention
attention is a limiting factor in fact
it might be the major limiting factor
according to some related work so here
we have a graph that shows performance
over how much workload you have so on
the right side you have very high
workload or high stress performance
tends to degrade but is also the case
that under very low worker load or
boredom performance will also degrade so
the key concept here is that we want the
direct interface focused dynamically so
what do we mean well here's a designing
station one design instantiation
automated drug timers and attentional
prompts so one thing that we can do is
we can say if you're going to reduce
epinephrine in five minutes you
shouldn't have to write that down or
remember it we can keep track of that
for you and let you know how long is
left so that when you're have that
serendipitous look up in your when
you're habituated to look up at the
screen regularly you can keep track of
things easily so this addresses the
problem by having the cognitive eight
surge is an intentional aid as well so
this is what our final design looked
like after the participatory design and
observation one of the things that we
one of the principles that we like to
use is focus plus context so what we try
to do here is we try to focus on the
main item now atropine and give a little
bit of context of what's happened before
and what's about to happen after in the
procedure so that wraps up the first
inventing let's move on to evaluating so
some of the key questions we had in
evaluating these dynamic aids where do
dynamic procedure aids support crisis
response and do nine Amick procedure
aids outperform paper aids in the
support to investigate this hypothesis
embedded in this system we developed the
narrative simulation approach which
makes use of pre time scenario and
interface slides narrative simulation
inspired by the mega code video training
materials presents scenarios in a linear
fashion no matter how the participant
responds the participant sees a slide
based presentation which automatically
advances to tell the patient's story so
who were our participants well we had
nine medical students and 29 MDS come
through and run our narrative
simulations and here the key to
narrative simulation is that people
respond differently they do different
things at different time and these
differences compound over the course of
a real situation so how do we get to
compare across people in the nerve one
of the ways that we do that is by
putting the scenario on rails so in this
way no matter what the participant
answers to any particular question
they're set back on the right path the
path of the scenario whether that's
right or not and then they're asked
another question assuming that they had
followed the path of the scenario in
this way we get about 30 roughly
independent measures of course across
each narrative simulation as the
participants answer 30 questions we
think this will actually be a useful way
to study in expert performance in many
domains not just in medicine so this is
our setup now let's quickly look at a
video and see what it looked like from
so one thing to notice is on the right
we have a distractor task every time a
colored circle appears they have to
respond to that quickly on the far left
we have the scenario breezing presented
on one screen with text and in the
middle which you can't see in this shot
but we'll see in the next we have our a
on a second screen you'll notice that it
was every couple you know 5 to 10
seconds that they have to respond to
this distractor task we asked our
participants to answer questions out
loud and this way we get a feel for what
they were imagining what should happen
next
with thermal pulse or responsive ok
start fluid bolus started on an
epinephrine drip so what do the
scenarios actually look like I'll walk
you through a quick slides here but I
won't belabor it too much we give some
background information
we give some setup and then we give some
of the information that's actually on
the vitals dispute blaze and on the
machines in the room finally we ask a
question and give the participant 10
seconds to respond to that question
so we had two measures here we had one
measure which was their score and
answering the questions we had a second
measure which was their own percept
their own perceived score and answering
these questions we asked them like how
many questions do you feel like you miss
and how much do you think that the
different aids you used helped you on
this task so here's our baseline this is
performance with no aid with paper aids
we saw a small difference but it wasn't
statistically significant however with
dynamic aids we saw a large improvement
in addition doctors actually self-assess
about the same scale as the real results
showed so if we look here about five
percent on paper and about fifteen
percent on dynamic we can actually
overlay that on top of this graph to get
a feel for what the doctors thought they
would have performed at from our
baseline so it's it's in the ballpark so
this is evidence that the principles
that we've been using design these aids
of making things easier to find and
reducing friction and using the aids are
actually paying off we've given them a
large screen display that's easy to look
that we've made it fast to use and
relevant to the context they're in and
we've given them timers to help remember
when things are coming up something else
worth noting is that when you break in
between med students and the full
medical doctors there's an interesting
difference in how much the aids actually
helped so the doctors and made about an
eight point difference in their score on
average but the medical students
actually made about a 20 point
difference on average now there's a
story that gets told that you don't want
to go to the hospital in July because
that's when all the new residents come
in that's when all the people who are
just Mehta students arrived and if that
story is really true these chi
of cognitive aids maybe one way of
mitigating that problem it's also
interesting to note that our results for
paper are different from what previous
research has shown we believe that
minimal training and the artificially
constrained question answering intervals
may contribute to this difference so
narrative simulation is a great method
for quickly testing hypotheses with John
bhasin we ran a ten-person
within-subjects test looking at if
providing a mobile aid and route to the
crisis would help so here the
participants were given an aid they were
asked to run to where the simulation was
taking place and then they stood in
front of the screens very set up very
much like last time we had a really
surprising finding that early diagnosis
was actually worse for those people who
had n route condition possibly two to
mismatch between how much people thought
they had remembered and what they
actually remembered from using the aid
while on the move narrative simulation
was key to letting it is quickly get
some insight onto this issue from a
medical perspective a narrative
simulation isn't well understood yet our
line of our one line of future work is
to look at how performance in a
narrative stimulation links to patient
outcome measures similar to what has
been done for those high fidelity
simulations where we did our observation
this would help us understand how the
skills being evaluated in a narrative
simulation relate to the skills that
doctor used during real crisis response
allowing us to further improve narrative
simulations and be able to predict how
results obtained a narrative simulations
would impact real performance another
interesting use for the narrative
simulations could be as part of a larger
ecosystem where it's a very inexpensive
tool that doctors to use frequently
where they can only get into these high
fidelity simulations occasionally
so let's take a little bit closer look
on how important speed is we ask the
ourselves these questions how long does
it take to find an answer on the
different cognitive aid designs and what
major design principles can lead to
faster search times well we know from
the related work that latency changes
behavior if you're driving in a car and
you have to use your radio or GPS or god
forbid you're trying to send a text
message on your cell phone you would
take your eyes off the road when you
glance down to use this device your task
is fast you look up before you have
drifted very far and correct your
steering to stay in the lane however
driving performance degrades as glance
time increases what kind of glance times
matter for driving well ones show
studies showed that about twelve percent
of glance times are above 1.6 seconds
and glance times above 1.6 seconds
account for eighty-six percent of
observed collisions but even very small
latency on routine tasks can
significantly impact behavior brute lag
found that adding between 100 and 400
milliseconds latency to the Google
search page actually reduced the daily
number of searches and the disaffected
proportional to the time that the user
was exposed to the added latency so
small timing differences can make
qualitative changes in how people behave
so glance times in the o.r people have
looked a little bit at glance times in
the o.r and it turns out that on average
people are looking at the monitors for
these are flipped sorry 3.7 seconds and
at the patient for on average 7.2
seconds at a glance in addition they do
you know in non-crisis they'll do about
five looks per minute at the patient and
they'll do about four looks per minute
at the monitors and for those monitors
about 75% of the looks that they do are
actually three seconds or less so these
are very short not quite as short as
driving but very short glance times
so let's look at the aids that we want
to test we did it within subjects study
where every participant saw each of the
five different aid styles and 15
questions on each of those aids this is
what current best practices this is a
set of aids where they've grouped the
steps into logical blocks that help
constrain the visual search that were
designed by our collaborators at
Stanford this is what we call an
enhanced Gawande version designing by
our team to try to improve on Gawande
zaid in a static format step blocks are
used along with the object actions in
language we talked about and information
patches we're visually separable regions
like the drugs or the visual alignment
of words help people find things quickly
fourth we had to pick the graphic aid in
this aid for each item they try to
create a memorable visual anchor to help
people find and come back to those items
quickly and finally we tested our
dynamic aid okay to show you what kind
of tasks were being performed it will
require just a little bit of our
audience participation so raise your
hand if you've attended CPR training
that's pretty good actually more than
fifty percent nice okay so I want
everybody to look at the picture that I
should aid that I show you and raise
your hand when you found out with the
dosages for the drug vasopressin ready
go
alright we've got about half of you in
about 10 seconds which is surprisingly
similar to the results that we saw now
let's do that once more but this time
with a different aid design again look
for the drug vasopressin and the dosage
ready go awesome it's like sub 2 seconds
it's even better than I expected alright
so what kind of data are we collecting
when we do these studies well what you
guys were doing was looking across the
aid frantically trying to find
vasopressin you may have started on the
left where it said epinephrine or
vasopressin and then realized that that
wasn't where the drug dosage was and
then looked off to the right of the
screen where it said that the drug
dosage was 40 units or in this case 32
so what did we find we found the gwanda
aids on a median time of about eight
seconds now it's worth noting here that
this is the log plot and there actually
is a log normal distribution here so the
averages are further out due to high
outliers we also found that the
pictographic and the enhanced go on day
we run approximately the same level
overall the block aid was marginally
better but not quite statistically
significant and the dynamic aids were
significantly faster to answer questions
overall than any of the other aids as
you witnessed however there's more to
the story if we break up performance by
the 15 different questions that we ask
aids did not perform equally they
performed well on some but poorly on
others and statistical terms there was a
strong interaction effect between stayed
style and the question being asked so
here we have an example where the block
aid in Blue has reformed very poorly it
has almost a 20-second average time
however over here on the right we see
the blue is done quite with a blockade
is done quite well and it's the gowanda
aid which is done quite poorly so let's
take a look closer looking first and see
what's happening here so this question
was what is the appropriate ventilation
rate or how many breaths should you give
per minute during CPR in the color block
which did poorly we see that a lot of
people spent time looking at the red box
here now that box is where the CPR
information is contained but one of the
reasons why this way did poorly on this
task was that the answer the ventilation
rate is at the top of this second box
down here where you can see people have
started to look so people spend a lot of
time looking where they thought the
information should be before they
actually moved on to where the
information was here in the enhanced
Gawande we see the CPR section and one
spot right here where the information is
so the information was actually low
dicated where people expected it to be
and all the CPR information was located
together so let's take a look at that
second question in this question that we
asked how many joules or how high should
the shock be when you're defibrillating
a patient
so we see here is they spend a lot of
time on the right-hand section which is
labeled defibrillator but there's no
information there about how high the
shock should be then we see the person
look up and down the left-hand column
this is because the left-hand column is
a sequence of repeated steps where in
only one or two places that you actually
find the shock setting which of this
case says shock at a medium setting
medium setting isn't a technical term
now has changed for the study as a note
so this is what the heat map would look
like for that I trace people looked a
lot here where the defibrillator was
they check that what these boxes were
then they spent a lot of time looking up
and down this column trying to find the
jewel to shock at now if we look at the
the parallel heat map for the dynamic
aid we see the people found to
fibrillate and then they found the
jewels the search was very focused there
wasn't a lot of looking around the
color-block did pretty well it was
actually the second best at this task
they have their defibrillate right here
located at the top now this their
strategy in general of limiting visual
search was relatively accessible overall
the pictographic here shows again one
highlight here where the answer is and
one iconic picture but the results
weren't too bad they were in the middle
in this case the image gave the people
something to anchor on quickly and then
they found the defibrillate right after
that but there is some amount lost that
it is important to point out that there
is some amount of looking at every
single one of these boxes which means
that some part is a pin looked
everywhere on that aid
finally we show a fail the case of an
attempt to translate some elements of
our dynamic style into the static paper
form the problem here is that we
followed the gowanda aid too closely
poorly representing that repeated cycle
in replicated blocks this led the
multiple similar targets and longer dr.
search for this case this example is
given to illustrate a point well we
develop a number of design concepts that
can be used to generate aids we also
employ our method to evaluate the
detailed use of an aid and identify what
went wrong we really think that
generating these aids is an important
part of what our work can contribute if
you look at the previous work on Gawande
zaid this is their methods section for
how they went about designing their
aides they got a multi-disciplinary
expert panel together in a room they all
sat down and talked for a long time and
formally review the content and design
of the checklists so this doesn't give
us a lot of help if we want to do our
own checklists although they are clearly
experts and do a good job so at a high
level we have these 5 guidelines that
are instantiated across all of these
aids these are not just visual
techniques they reach into the content
to help better express medical ideas we
are linking types of content and types
of visual expression so here the
compressed object action language that I
was talking to you about information
patches which is instantiated in some of
our designs as columns and separate
boxes for the drugs step blocks so the
blockade you can put similar content
into a box to link it together pick the
grams so using some kind of iconic
representation that's helping people
search and remember where the
information is and focus plus context so
you want to use the context of the
crisis in order to show just what's
important at the current time
so we've used I tracking to evaluator
design and we're certainly not the first
to do this I tracking has been used to
evaluate webpage design for a while some
of the findings that they have is that
on web pages the top left is much more
salient and the scattering depends can
be tasked dependent or not as dependent
depending on how the researchers measure
and some work from psychology has also
looked at web page design and I tracking
trying to figure out can top-down search
overcome bottom-up visual processing so
another way to say this is if you're
looking for something well you find will
you do a different search pattern than
if you're just looking around the page
and having whatever's visually salient
draw your attention in this case they
did support the top-down can overcome
bottom up for their search task and
finally some people have shown that new
web page designs people will adapt to
quickly so if you take the navigation
bar from a web page and you put it in a
new location as long as you're
consistent for that web page people will
very quickly adapt and use it just like
they would use any other web page so
through all of this I tracking and
principles we revised our dynamic aid to
integrate some of those things that we
learn from the eye tracker here we see a
stronger object action format and
columns that help create information
patches for people to look when they
want to find the topic on the left and
then know exactly on the right where the
column is again here's an example of
consistent drug representation you
always give the name the dosage and
extra text always in the same format so
that people can quickly read it and
understand it so everything that we've
talked about so far is related to using
aids for health professionals in
medicine there's also an opportunity to
make personal aides that help
individuals make better decisions about
their health day to day and another
project that I worked on here at
Stanford we tried to develop some
personal health aides
cardiovascular disease cancer stroke and
type 2 diabetes have all been
demonstrated ly linked to a small number
of key health behaviors including
regular physical activity and the
reduction of prolonged daily sitting
time now regular physical activity means
about 20 minutes per day of brisk
walking the goal of this project
codenamed miles was use mobile phones to
promote physical activity and reduce
sedentary time we designed three
different interventions each is a mobile
app using different theories derived
from behavioral science literature the
first was an analytic framing so this
motivational frame was giving people
numbers asking them to do goal-setting
and having them be very involved in
tracking their own activity the section
mode second motivational frame was
social so here we had people compare
themselves to others both says team
members collaboration and as other teams
competition here the goal wasn't to walk
the most yourself what the goal was that
you have your team walk more than the
other team third we have an effect or
emotional design here the goal was to
make your little avatar a flying bird
happier and fly higher so you didn't get
any numbers about how much were you you
more you were walking but you did get
this little bird that would give you
some feedback if you like the bird then
maybe that helped so the results from an
eight-week behavioral adoption period
indicated that all three applications
were sufficiently robust to
significantly improve regular to regular
moderate to vigorous intensity physical
activity and decrease leisure time
sitting so let's do a quick recap talked
about inventing dynamic procedure aids
we talked about evaluating them with
narrative simulation talked about in
deeper investigation
using eye-tracking to look at layout and
visual design and finally we talked a
little bit about how aids can come and
become personal patient health aids to
help you make better health decisions
and really the main takeaway of all this
work the dynamic procedure aids do
better than paper aidid's by utilizing
context and design principles there are
a couple of really interesting
directions that we can go from here we
can start to build an ecosystem of
devices that can include personal
displays like Google glass we can also
come full circle and study dynamic
procedure aids in the high fidelity
simulators where we did our initial
observations or we can bring dynamic
procedure aids to do new domains
anything from cooking directions to
writing research papers to programming
might benefit from aids that can present
standardized procedures based on
utilizing context
so I just want to give some quick thank
yous for all of this my contributors
Leslie will christen jon kyl Larry stew
and Scott I couldn't have done any of
this work without your help my advisor
Scott who has worked patient with Lee
with me be4 these last five years and
has always been willing to go the extra
mile to help me out my committee members
and everyone else has helped make this
project a success finally my friends and
family I couldn't have done it without
all of your support my mom who's here in
spirit pop you've been an amazing role
model all of my life and I've learned to
follow my passions and work and my
hobbies through you I wouldn't be here
without you Jason I'm constantly
thankful that I have you as a friend and
as a brother and Maria you help me stay
balanced insane every day I'm a better
and happier person because of you and
with that I'll take questions
yeah citizen Jesse so how much man don't
have to transcribe one of each like the
Golani thing to do your system is there
some semi automated ways to do that so
it took a year to translate the gowanda
age into our system the first time
around in the future what we're hoping
is actually to build a tool that will
help amateur people who are not
designers to do this so you can imagine
something like an Excel spreadsheet with
the different titles and levels of
detail that can be automatically
translated rule-based into something
that looks like the dynamic aid yeah
it's stripping you're talking about how
they did the kiwanda aids initially and
you have experts who have lots of
experience and they design something and
then you have the dynamic aids and then
there's any able to do these evaluations
um that's focusing on sort of the object
action thing and so on what happens if
you look at where the primary errors
occur so if you could actually watch
what people are doing in real medical
emergencies and if you found out that
there's a few things that they always do
that are real problems and then less and
less and less than so would that change
the way you do the dynamic aids because
obviously you're not going to be able to
deal with out the static ones but with
the dynamic age how would you take that
into account yeah so one of the things
we actually did in our original designs
was look at the five ages and tease so
these are the underlying causes for
cardiac arrest and one of the things
that they started off as ages and teased
because there as a memory tool you know
there's five H's you know there's five
tease and it's a way for doctors to help
remember if they've gone through
everything and thought about all the
causes but what we realized was that
some causes are more likely than other
causes are and we actually reordered
that list so that when you get the
cognitive aid that comes up and says hey
have you considered this cause it's the
most common cause first and then you
work through that list in order
yeah Michael actually bouncing on that
question your main takeaway was that
dynamic aides were like a big winner yes
I'm wondering what is it about the
dynamic nature that then making it the
where is is it something inherent about
the interactivity of the systems you're
building comparison something that you
could flatten onto a static image or
print out the reasons you game the
design principles you talking about
largest like they could apply to a
static case easily as well yeah
absolutely so let me pull up that one of
the graphs that I showed and I just got
to find it unroll your dynamic made into
a big long list yeah absolutely so so um
I think that I would point to this graph
to kind of answer that question so one
of the things that we're able to do is
just put less text on the screen which
means it's easier to learn so I would
compare that to increasing skill so it's
easier to become highly skilled with a
dynamic aid and since we're looking at
tasks that have a very short time window
if you can be i'm highly skilled and you
can be formed better without any
training for example in our study aids
then that might be give a big win over
paper aids which would take a lot more
training so you can imagine let's say
you trained on this paper aids for an
hour you might be able to push that
curve up more like the dynamic aid where
you're performing higher and faster
because you're familiar with the aids
and so I kind of suggests that the paper
aids are also useful and a lot of those
principles are also useful but because
there's so much more text there you're
going to have to spend a little time
learning it first before it's really
going to pay off benefits you're saying
is that the big one with the dynamic
eight is that you can manage attention
more effectively yes y absolute equality
because the question he was it's clear
that there's a high correlation between
how fast you
a little leery of a Lex is faster
and you're winning on the base of that
now that assumes that the thing you want
is always there so the page which has
way too much text on it may have stuck
which you didn't manage to get on to the
page there and if you want to actually
test the time then it's the time to go
to another page and find it and so on so
on yeah they are testing that we did a
little so with the eye tracking study we
did a little mini study on how
page-turning would affect the times and
it turns out that having something
that's not on the page if you have one
page versus two but you can see them at
the same time it doesn't make much of a
difference but as soon as you have to
turn that page it actually does impact
the amount of time it takes you to find
the answer because you kind of have to
search the whole page before you know
it's not there and then you can look at
the next page or search enough of the
page you can guess that it's not there
so it does make a difference and so for
something like the dynamic aid this
again would play into that if it's not
up on the screen you can't find it fast
and so one of the things that actually
we would like to do is to verify our
intuition that they're actually easy to
keep up to date and keep the context
correct on those dynamic aids yeah Green
times but you talk about learning use d8
itself and the study is all about
performance of skills they already have
this assists have you considered these
tools as teaching aids for beginners
yeah absolutely um so one of the things
that we think one of the things that
we've been thinking about is that people
are not just going to start picking up
these aids if they've never used them
before but if you can get them to use
them at med school if you can get them
as a training aid then as they get to be
residents and full doctors they'll carry
that with them and so one of the ways
and long-term changing of practice you
can kind of build a tool for training
using your aids or using the narrative
simulation and then allow that as a
vehicle for carrying forward the aids
into real practice yeah question related
to that hub with the 20-point difference
the med school suits when they use the
aid is there concern that people if you
if you were to move as into like the
teaching
they might become too accustomed to a
particular aid and so you know if
they're faced with a new even dynamic
aid but things are laid out in different
content that or context that may just
negatively affect performance absolutely
so we are in the middle of analyzing
some data that we're just running this
weekend last week that is comparing our
new dynamic plus plus to the dynamic aid
and kind of it has some mixed results
right now and we think that one of the
reasons for that may be that they train
now they've seen that dynamic aid in our
study three or four times all of a
sudden we've changed the layout on them
it looks almost the same but it's not
and that can be I think a pretty big
issue we also had our collaborators
they've done some looking into like
preferences for AIDS and it just turns
out that people always prefer the aid
that they've used before no matter how
good or bad they are so as soon as you
learn know one of them you don't want to
change its you know you don't want to
have to learn something new yeah should
hear a little bit one of the things I
thought was interesting from a process
and evaluation perspective was your use
of narrative simulation then they did
with a nice job of articulating some of
the benefits certainly it's less costly
than some of the more detailed
simulation we're going to get any like
verification or evidence on the pike may
be negative trade-offs things that you
saw in the more high fidelity
simulations than you are unable to
observe and narrative and second to that
just wondering you might generalize what
are other areas of HCI were you think
narrative simulation might be a useful
technique brothers to adopt yeah
absolutely so the first question um
remind me of that really quickly Trader
Joe's benefits absolutely when you go to
that level of fidelity so one of the
things that you miss is the difference
between verbalizing knowledge and
actually enacting knowledge so we have
some doctors who come in who are they
just off the top of their head instantly
know all the answers and some doctors
who maybe don't instantly off the hub of
the head they can't verbalize them but
they're still potentially good doctors
we're not saying you know that they're
bad doctors here but it's all about in a
narrative simulation verbalizing the
answers to the questions as opposed to
actually going and doing it like drawing
up the drugs so there's some potential
trade offs here about you know it's more
like school and a little bit less like
real life
and second question is where what other
domains do we think that we could use
for narrative simulation so a couple of
the ones that we've talked about and we
you know spent some time trying to work
through was so things like cooking
cooking is an interesting one because it
seems kind of straightforward but it's
got a lot of the same properties it's
time sensitive if you make some mistakes
over here then you're going to push off
something else things get off you have a
bad meal so being able to actually
evaluate aids for cooking might be one
place that we can use this and just
other places where you need a lot of
expertise so if you can imagine I mean
airplane pilots are another example
where they need a lot of expertise you
can't just test them anywhere and so
maybe now you can start you know
engaging them in a narrative simulation
where they have to show some of that
knowledge and you can also do it much
less expensively than a full simulator
thanksgivi scuba-dive awesome things to
check yes I think actually my safety
chain that even though they didn't think
of it in the same process absolutely
yeah yeah cool all right thank you
everyone for being here
you